[Music]
guys that are Kong standing should be
here any second I'm sorry for the way
it's fine hello sorry I'm late
who some dog tried to marry my shin on
the way here
alright who wants the car okay let's get
started
the jungle is quiet too quiet I don't
like this one bit
it's fine we're armed guys do you hear
that
suddenly Kong rises into view he lets
out a huge roar what do you know I'm
saying what he was what do you look at a
huge roar dude he's a giant love 8 but
what if he was in the poetry like the
bigger the Kong the longer the show um I
have to make a phone call okay where'd
you get this guy oh my got a piece don't
worry about it British he's method actor
dude you awesome till you started that
poetry